Con toda la legítima preocupación acerca
del SIDA y la fiebre aviar y de ello escucharemos al
brillante Dr. Brillant más tarde hoy,
quiero hablar acerca de la otra pandemia formada por
las enfermedades cardiovasculares, la diabetes y la hipertensión,
las cuales en al menos el 95% de las personas
se pueden prevenir por completo con
tan sólo cambiar la dieta y el estilo de vida.
Lo que está pasando es que se está
dando una globalización de las enfermedades, que la gente
empieza a comer como nosotros, a vivir como nosotros
y a morir como nosotros. Por ejemplo, en una sola generación
Asia pasó de tener una de las tasas más bajas de
enfermedades del corazón, obesidad y diabetes a una
de las más altas. Y en la mayoría de los países
de África, las enfermedades cardiovasculares
igualan las muertes por VIH y el SIDA.
Así que tenemos una crítica ventana de oportunidad
para marcar una importante diferencia
que puede afectar la vida de millones
de personas y practicar medicina preventiva
a una escala global.
Las enfermedades cardiacas y cardiovasculares siguen matando
a más gente, no sólo en este país sino también
en todo el mundo, que cualquier otra combinación de lo demás,
sin embargo casi todos podemos prevenirlo por completo.
No sólo lo podemos prevenirlo, también lo podemos
revertir. En los últimos casi 29 años,
hemos podido demostrar que con un simple cambio de
dieta y estilo de vida, usando estas herramientas
de estado de arte y alta tecnología costosa
para probar lo poderosas que puede ser estas intervenciones
de baja tecnología y costo: la arteriografía
cuantitativa, antes y después de un año
y escáners cardiacos PET.
Lo mostramos hace unos meses, publicamos
el primer estudio que muestra cómo uno puede detener
o revertir el avance del cáncer de próstata haciendo
cambios en la dieta y el estilo de vida, y disminuir en
un 70% el crecimiento del tumor o inhibir el
crecimiento del tumor, comparado con sólo
9% en el grupo de control.
Aquí en la espectroscopia de MRI y MR, se muestra
la actividad del tumor de próstata en rojo, como ven
disminuyó después de un año.
Ahora bien, hay una epidemia de obesidad. Dos terceras partes de
adultos y el 15% de niños. Lo que en realidad me preocupa
es que la diabetes ha crecido en un 70% en los
últimos 10 años y quizá esta sea la primera
generación en que nuestros hijos tenga una
duración de vida más corta que la nuestra.
Esto es lamentable y prevenible.
Estos no son resultados electorales, son personas,
son el número de personas obesas por
estado, empezando en '85, '86, '87 que son del
sitio de la CDC, '88, '89, '90, '91 y aquí hay
una nueva categoría, '92, '93, '94, '95, '96,
'97, '98, '99, 2000, 2001, se pone peor.
Estamos como involucionando. (Risas)
¿Qué podemos hacer al respecto? Bueno, como saben,
la dieta que encontramos que puede revertir
el cáncer y las enfermedades cardiacas es la dieta asiática.
Sin embargo, la gente en Asia está empezando a comer
como nosotros, por lo cual se están empezando
a enfermar como nosotros.
Así que he estado trabajando con muchas compañías
grandes de alimentos, que pueden hacer que comer
alimentos saludables sea divertido, sexy, crujiente, moderno y
conveniente. Presido la junta consultiva de
McDonald's, Pepsico, Conagra y Safeway y
pronto la del Del Monte y todos encuentran
que es buen negocio.
Las ensaladas que ven en McDonald's provienen
de este trabajo, van a tener una ensalada asiática.
En Pepsi, dos terceras partes del crecimiento de
sus ingresos provienen de mejores alimentos.
Así que si podemos hacer esto, entonces podemos
liberar recursos para comprar medicinas que en realidad
se necesitan más para tratar el SIDA y el VIH y
para prevenir la gripe aviar. Gracias